[Musique]
dans le milieu des années 90 il avait
dit haut et fort qu'ils voulaient
changer la physionomie de cette commune
de schoelcher élu en 2008 puis réélu en
2014 luc louison clémente était avec
nous dans son caddie bonjour monsieur le
maire bonjour un mandat et demi déjà la
tête de la commune vous dites quoi ce
matin mais tous les ans clément t1
celles et ceux qui disent que celle cher
n'avance pas que schelcher n'y arrive
pas que son maire vous n'avez pas tenu
ses promesses
écoutez ça c'est maurizio le temps qui
le dit
je résume je n'ai pas les mêmes échos du
terek vous même l'une des principales
innovations que nous avons apportées en
arriver aux responsabilités c était
justement de faire de la démocratie
participative
véritable mode de gestion à schoelcher
et pour cela très tôt nous avons compris
l'intérêt qu'il y avait à travailler
avec la population de manière très
étroite
c'est une opposition apportée par vivra
cherchant vengeance chez oui ça il faut
le dire j'ai mal dire lors de la
première mandature nous avons organisé
quelque chose comme 486 réunion de
quartier ouais ce qui est énorme ça nous
continuons au cours de la deuxième
mandature
ça a du sens pour nous et cela nous a
permis dans un contexte budgétaire
particulièrement contraint d'être sûr
que chaque euro que nous dépensons soit
justement bien utilisé et est-ce que
vous avez l'impression de répondre à
l'impatience de cette population parce
que vous l'avez dit les caisses sont
vides
le budget de la ville de schoelcher
c'est 30 millions d'euros à peu près
pour une ville de plus de 20000
habitants et surtout cette incapacité de
désendettement qui est l'équation à
50000 est connue de chercheurs
chercheurs n'a filtré gros efforts au
niveau de l'endettement l'une de mes
premières priorités en argot
responsabilité c'était justement de
lancer un gros programme de chasse au
gaspi et de maîtrise de nos dépenses et
de ce point de vue s'agissant de
l'aspect emprunt que vous évoquez
actuellement nous avons effectivement
aussi des à la renégociation de tous les
emprunts aujourd'hui nous avons un
encours d'emprunt de l'ordre de 12
millions d'euros
nous avons tous moyens
compris lorsqu on fait l'addition entre
le variable et le fixe aux environs de
2,2 pour cent ce qui est très correct
aujourd'hui et nous avons une échéance
d'emprunt annuel de l'ordre de 1 million
cinq communes de 20000 habitants si très
correct je suis pour ma part très
satisfaits alors je reprends la question
que répondez vous à ceux qui disent que
votre marge de manoeuvre est quasiment
inexistant annonce est une réalité ça je
n'ai jamais caché il ya la population de
chéchia nyala martini très tôt nous
avons pris le parti de dire la vérité
aujourd'hui l'association et chercher à
qualité elle nous avons un budget de
l'ordre de 35 millions d'euros 26
millions en fonctionnement et 9 millions
en investissement sur cette base là nous
avons des recettes qui ont diminué
depuis 2008 de l'ordre d'à peu près 4
millions 6 avec des charges qui elles
aussi ont diminué mais moins vite de
l'ordre de 3 millions 3 donc 15 courses
à peu près de 2 07 13 % de baisse de 11%
de baisse des charges c'est encore
insuffisant et nous sommes pris dans ce
qu'ils pouvaient peu convenu d'appeler
aujourd'hui un effet ciseau c'est-à-dire
un point de rupture entre les
augmentations qui peuvent être vertueuse
et vertueuse parlons des recettes et la
baisse des charges
alors pour ça nous y travaillons
vraiment très très sérieusement 7,4 en
tête
il arrive aux responsabilités j'avais
quelque chose comme un coefficient de
rigidité c'est-à-dire frais de personnel
+ remboursement d'emprunt de l'ordre de
95%
ça veut dire qu'on a une marge de
manoeuvre de manoeuvre nul quasiment nul
aujourd'hui nous sommes aux environs de
80 81 2% légère amélioration miraton
gérants amélioration avec comme vous le
savez une masse salariale qui est très
difficile à maîtriser mais que nous
maîtrisons tout de même à schoelcher
sachez le chaque mois je verse plus de 2
millions d'euros d'un de deux salaires
est-ce que de temps en temps vous
entendez cette population qui dit amiens
pack avancer nos packs away n'ont pas
cadré de nouveaux projets nous pâques à
ouennougha aurait plutôt ses vielles
structure de l'acquis 4 décembre qui
passera mais c'est pas le sentiment que
j'ai quand je réalise
vous à dire aux dans le nez dans le
guidon monsieur le même nez moi-même
line une grande majorité de jeunes
chinois
je vais vous fait je pars faire un scoop
ce matin vous lisant une très grande
majorité de chez de martinique et veuves
ira chercher le cheikh est l'une des
villes la plus attractive de la
martinique ça je je ne le tiens pas de
moi ni de la majorité municipale
c'est une réalité quand vous demande aux
martiniquais où il aurait aimé vivre
il vous dit cher pour voir si celle cher
c'est une ville qui joli ça il faut le
dire c'est une ville qui bien
entretenues ça il faut le dire aussi
c'est une ville de l'intelligence nous
accueillons pratiquement toutes les
structures de formation supérieure sur
le territoire de la commune de
schoelcher c'est une ville au niveau de
laquelle nous nous occupons de nos
seniors de manière parfaite
les cols bleus les que le ville ville
universitaire et pourquoi on ne se
refait pas davantage par exemple sur ce
potentiel universitaire c'est quand même
5000 plus de 5000 étudiants sur le
campus de schoelcher ça n'apparaît pas
tellement ça ça ne respire pas ça ne
transpire pas dans vos nous sommes en
relation très étroite avec l'université
yeux de ce point de vue je vais vous
dire un exemple pour vous dire la dirai
que nous apportons à la liaison avec
l'université dans le journal municipal
nous réservons une page pleine et
entière à l'université pour qu'elles
puissent communiquer comme elle l'entend
ça a du sens pour nous a énormément le
sens et quand je dis que celle ci est la
ville de l'intelligence ce n'est pas
seulement un slogan nous lui donnant
véritablement un contenu à cette manière
d'exprimer les gens vers 2 en 2h02 de
permettre à l'université d'exprimer sexy
mais dans cette dans cette page est-ce
que vous avez des projets par exemple
pour ce pur surf et je le répète encore
une fois sur cette jeunesse
martiniquaise qui vient apprendre qui
vient étudier ça permettra un
rayonnement extraordinaire monstres nous
sommes dessus nous sommes dessus de
l'eau quatre projets développement que
nous avons mis en place avec justement
là la proximité du palais des congrès la
proximité de l'université celle du pôle
commercial la chambre de commerce vient
d'ouvrir et la création dans quelques
semaines je pense tout est déjà ok là
dessus d'une zone d'activités dédiée aux
services c'est une manière de jeter le
pont justement entre le savoir il aussi
mais aussi l'entreprise alors que vous
aviez dit 1 lors de vos campagnes avant
votre élection que vous auriez besoin de
mandat pour pour
et rééquilibrer des finances et de
deuxième mandat pour lancer des projets
qu'en est il de ce fameux aménagement du
front de mer
là dessus vous poser le problème du
développement de la stratégie
développement de la ville de chercheurs
aujourd'hui dans un an peut-être il n'y
a pas d'argent dans ce domaine la sortie
après l'argent des parfums dans la zone
le préciser dans ce domaine là notre
stratégie va dans plusieurs directions
la première consiste à dire qu'il faut
consolider les acquis depuis que était
acquis depuis 2008 dans ce sens que le
problème de l'eau par exemple h et le
cher avant notre arrivée aux
responsabilités
l'eau est un vrai problème à schoelcher
ne collait pas naturellement du rove et
du robinet notamment période d'étiage
celle ci a été l'une des communes à
s'offrir le plus possible ils arrivent
ils en ont souffert et voilà le problème
de l'eau est un lointain très très très
lointain souvenir donc excellent travail
a été fait là dessus il faut pas baisser
les bras en matière d'assainissement nos
précieux ce même travail pour faire en
sorte que la qualité des eaux de
baignade de celle chair puisse demeurer
lors si nous avons fait des progrès
extraordinaires
l'amélioration du cadre de vie à travers
la confection de trottoirs nous avons
construit des kilomètres de trottoirs
nous avons refait certain nombre de
routes
je suis particulièrement fier d'un
projet que nous avons cherché serait le
méchant vous qualifiez vous gêne de ce
trottoir à seule fin mais ça me va
ça me va ça veut dire que je suis en
pleine proximité est en plein de
commandes y redire et dimensions de bien
vivre ou bien être de la population en
m'occupant des priorités du quotidien as
les jeux vidéo et quelques chétifs de
cette route entre le faire je viendrai
la ville tous les arômes est arrivé
juste avant d'y arriver vous dire
combien nous sommes fiers aujourd'hui
équipe municipale de la ville de
schoelcher d'avant réalise un projet de
peu vieux de plus de 60 ans je veux
parler de la liaison entre les deux r d
l'ancienne route de celle cher et la
route comment dire de cluny
là on dit aujourd'hui la sécurité
sociale tout l'administratif d'un projet
vieux de plus de 60 ans que nous avons
réalisés et qui les acclament énormément
succès alors passionnant la violence de
robin tout ça c'est vrai que c'était une
de tes rentrer traire vie c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'était une priorité pour
nous c'est mais la dr nous a fait
comprendre que cette route qui doit être
construit se trouvant sur une ligne f
c'est à dire une zone d'intérêt
floristique et faunistique
particulièrement important qui n'était
pas question pour eux de lui donner la
possibilité de défricher ce
reconstruire loin et à la population les
ai jamais parlé déjà la population j'ai
dû aujourd'hui je nous avons eu
aujourd'hui à changer leur fusil
d'épaulé et pas il ya pas très longtemps
de ça avec un certain nombre de procès
exécutif mais aussi le président marie
jeanne donc aussi exécutif nous envoyons
une rendre sur les lieux pour lui
expliquer ce que j'ai l'intention de
faire je vous le dis à très peu de mots
oui au niveau but de lens madame pas
loin du stade nous avons l'intention de
créer un giratoire avec un pont qui
passerait par le su la rivière 15
navires et qui déboucherait du côté de
la route 10 écoles qui pourrait
justement nous permettre de relier la
route de petit paradis grand paradis à
l'aider à fort de france ouest
si ce projet que nous allons substituer
au précédent si vous trouvez des fonds
on revient sur l'aménagement du front de
mer puisque dans le prolongement de cet
aménagement il ya quand même la
résorption de l'habitat insalubre à fond
batelière et c'est une promesse oui nous
sommes dessus pour écouter à la fois
matérielle vous allez voir que les
immeubles dow jones censés nous sommes
dessus vous avez commencé on a commencé
les blockhaus être construit sera
finalement ce sera fini que ce projet a
été lancé ce que j'entends c'est
exaspère si j'en ai ras je n'ai pas la
maîtrise totale des choses à niveau la
peau quoi parce que ce n'est pas moi qui
construit personnellement oui c'est vrai
que c'est un projet que nous pensons
terminer dans les dents dans le temps
dans les toutes prochaines années qui
arrivent et ce projet relativement long
la la la réhabilitation de forme
ateliers c'est un projet une fois de
plus ce qu'est vieux de pratiquement 40
à 50 ans c'est notre régie municipale
qui l'a pris à malraux à bras le corps
qu'il a lancée qui est en train de le
réaliser
ce sont les projets particulièrement
difficile il ya très peu de rhj qui a
été réussi en martinique
on sait ce sont deux valises ou
opérations si les voiles à résoudre cela
lui que beaucoup de maires hésitent à
enclencher pourquoi parce qu'elles sont
excessivement difficile mais au niveau
du développement jose rajoute un point
qui me paraît essentiel à mes yeux nous
avons fait de la politique fiscale un
levier économique particulièrement
importante iem développement c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pris la
décision de ne pas augmenter les impôts
nous humains sans qu'il entendait sans
vous le reconnaître nous utilisons les
impôts comme justement un moyen de
maîtriser les chiffres sont fixes
nomique nos cieux moyens de relancer
l'économie aujourd'hui on sait que la
consommation constitue l'élément clé
de la croissance au niveau de la
martinique nous avons décidé donc au
plan économique à schoelcher avec des
impacts sur la martinique de ne pas
augmenter les impôts pour ne pas peser
sur la consommation et c'est là que le
pas et c'est bien les élèves sur ses
tarifs clémente et ne pas ne pas ne pas
pénaliser comment dire la croissance
d'autres l'emploi non ce n'est pas
clémente et ça veut dire à schoelcher
nous avons une équipe de personnes
d'élus de tous bords qui réfléchissent
au quotidien qui n'ont pas de gros
moyens financiers mais comme j'aime à le
dire sous très souvent c'est pas parce
qu'une bague en or afin que nous pas ça
travaille au poker parce que nous raffin
en nous montrer tout ça ce n'est une
équipe soudée avec quand même quelques
effets quelques frictions
le secrétaire général de vivre à
schoelcher qui démissionnent nom du nord
c'est-à-dire à vivre h et le suivre chez
est un parti comme comment dire
tous les autres partis avec des hauts et
des bas dans son fonctionnement
le secrétaire général de livres à
schoelcher et toujours membres comment
dire de vivre à schoelcher fait son
travail d'élu de manière exemplaire
je n'ai strictement rien a dit au
contraire c'est un homme que j'apprécie
à la tâche à laquelle il est aujourd'hui
au niveau de la ville de schoelcher nous
parlions de félix catherine merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin du cru
louison clémente on rappelle que vous
êtes le maire de schoelcher merci
d'abriter avec michel trois villes de
martinique en terme de population merci
exactement merci bien
[Musique]